i'm bobby hundreds i'm the co-founder of
the hundreds i always say i do a little
bit of everything and a lot of nothing
and today i'm going to take you on a
tour of my collection
[Music]
as a designer and as a writer i'm most
inspired by drawing upon emotions and
nostalgia and sentimentality and so if
you look within the context of our brand
even
it's largely a nostalgia and
sentimentally based baseball cards that
would have probably been my first foray
into i'm actually collecting for the
specific purpose of collecting because
they might increase in value so baseball
cards then spoke to comic books and then
basketball cards came afterwards and so
i think i'm pretty much in everything
you know people ask me why i'm not into
watches i just don't wear watches i
don't like being mindful of time so
don't ever wait for
me this is just a fragment of everything
that i have i have even more
in rooms in the back and stashed away in
the archives and so sometimes i feel
like we have 90 000 square feet of
warehouse just to hold our collectibles
in our collections which is ridiculous
but within this immediate room i mean
you're looking at the breadth of my
entire life i'm looking around and i'm
seeing things that i had when i was five
and six years old there's garfield
household items
i'm a big garfield enthusiast of
anything i've collected in my life it's
probably garfield the most it started
with reading his comics and
me emulating jim davis the artist's
illustrations i always wanted to draw
cartoons and that was largely influenced
if not motivated by jim davis and
garfield secondarily to that jim davis
was also a master licensor the master of
licensing and
my childhood bedroom was garfield
pillowcases bed sheets erasers this was
my childhood clock the idea of my
favorite comic strip and cartoon not
being just something that i read and i
experience and interact with on a 2d
level but to be immersed in a garfield
world any way that i could consume and
collect garfield was really enjoyable
for me as a young kid because he was
like my best friend my attitude was
largely shaped by him i love lasagna to
this day because of garfield i don't
necessarily hate mondays but i've always
felt like when he says that he's just
being sarcastic i don't think he
actually hates anything and i think the
negativity is all a front with garfield
which
i drive with like i get that
i collect a lot of art and art comes in
all different forms and shapes and
ceramics have actually gotten quite
trendy over the last few years these are
sharif sharif is kind of leading the
charge and charging the lead he's just
the homie but also making these really
beautiful pieces of ceramics there's
just 10 pieces just chen is a really
incredible talented tattoo artist out of
canada but she's also gotten into
ceramics and a lot of this i think was
spurred if not inspired by what was
happening during the pandemic with
artists just trying to find different
lanes probably one of the most famous
and notable ceramics artists today is
seth rogen the actor seth has actually
gotten pretty proficient because he has
access
to the world's best ceramicist and so
he's learning from the best and he also
has access to the best materials and
tools but he really means it and he knew
that i had wanted one for so long and to
be a gift in one of these this is
probably one of my most prized
possessions if this entire place burns
down i'm going to come back for my seth
rogen piece right there
a lot of back to the future stuff when
we were younger there just weren't a lot
of back to the future memorabilia or
collectibles around and that generation
has grown up and the demand is there and
there's a marketplace for it it would
take me probably another lifetime to
configure this all you're looking at
some of it right here different bear
bricks and deloreans and uh
my wife got me that one for christmas
she actually got it for my son and then
i stole it because i was just like
you're not gonna care not the way that i
care about them i used to own the
world's best delorean it had 500 miles
on it it was preserved in a museum for
30 years before i bought it i don't have
it anymore it was using the bc boys last
music video it's been used in a bunch of
commercials i still miss the car and i
still miss the appeal of the design and
so i have a bunch of replica versions of
them from different parts of the film
series the gold delorean there are two
in the world it was part of an american
express campaign in 1981.
transformers did a 35th anniversary
version finally took them long enough to
make a time machine
the sneakers that i own people might
expect or anticipate that they're going
to be the most sensational sneakers out
there really expensive shoes that are
you know headline grabbers but they're
not
my favorite pair of sneakers in my
collection are always going to be my
converse chuck taylors and all stars the
end end-all be-all of what a good
sneaker is this is the alpha and omega
it's reduced down to its most classic
lines and shapes and you know nike is
embodied by a swoosh a converse all-star
like this is the logo the entire product
design it's really good for me
personally to look down at my feet and
just remember at the end of the day that
it's just canvas and rubber and we're
here to design and do good work but to
bring us back to our basics
i have air jordan 4s here because black
forest to me are the perfect sneaker
when i think of sneaker culture and
sneaker collecting you can't be in the
space without having black fours it
speaks to an air of design it's really
period specific but it also has
transcended multiple generations so in
the year 2022
an air jordan 4 i think is still really
relevant and meaningful and has its
place in sneaker culture
i have to speak on these when you scrub
through sneaker history you might be
hard-pressed to find many people
mentioning these but they speak to a
really specific
person who grew up in the 80s and 90s
and remember this period of reebok pump
when they were
larger than nike air it seems super
gimmicky now but to issue a sneaker for
tennis and the pump has been translated
into a fuzzy yellow tennis ball that was
just such an
innovative design choice
michael chang an asian american tennis
player who they were trying to position
as a rock star up against andre agassi
he was like the asian michael jordan to
me these are like asian jordans everyone
needs to know this was the asian
american jordan right here
you know this is just an homage to
virgil when he was dropping these shoes
i reached out to him to ask you know for
the connect and the plug and with
virgil's passing i
it's still really bizarre to me and to
many of us it feels like he's still very
present within
the culture and also within the universe
and i think it's because his design has
become so ubiquitous in our lives right
and so sneaker design and product design
and fashion have forever been impacted
if not the course has changed because of
virgil's fingerprint on it when i look
at these and i wonder what this is going
to do what it did for that generation of
sneakers over the last 10 years and then
what we will continue to do over the
forthcoming decades and how young people
will remember virgil's era of design
this is my way of understanding that
virgil and his work is immortal but of
all the sneakers that he worked on i
would say the prestos were my favorite
this is a very very famous chain it is
the hundreds ben baller chain it's just
funny because half the people believe
that it's real and half the people
thought it was fake and no matter what i
tell them they think it's the opposite
so to the people who believe it's real i
tell them
actually it's fake or it's real and
they're like
no it's probably the other way around so
nobody believes me anyway so i don't say
what it is if it's real or fake it's if
you want to believe it's three million
dollar chain that's up to you
rappers love coming in here wearing it
one of the last people to put this
around their neck was nipsy hustle we
got nipsy energy around the hundreds
been baller chain and if you ever run
into ben ben baller ask him about it
he'll tell you the full story that he
made the world's most expensive chain
and
it went to
the hundreds
here's some of my cameras and i'm not a
big camera collector but i am a
photographer when we started the
hundreds and when we started my blog in
2003 i had already been blogging a lot
and had been using this camera this is
the actual camera it's a canon rebel xt
pretty much at the nascent stage of
dslrs right so prosumer photography on a
digital level you know people are making
that transition from being film
photographers to digital and i started
documenting not just our lifestyle and
culture but the street culture and the
street fashion world around us and so
the hundreds and the story of our brand
and like
my personal journey my personal
narrative into this space
was seen through the lens of this camera
that you're looking at right here when
joey badass first visited the studio of
everything that was in the room he
gravitated towards this because he's
like man i live on that blog and was
staring at all those photos and wanted
to live that life so this is a real
relic
i probably have somewhere between like
75 and 100 different nfts on different
levels the first nft that i fell in love
with and i started collecting was crypto
punks they're arguably one of the first
on the blockchain gary vaynerchuk
persuaded me to buy it i was in the
middle of dinner he's just like getting
on the zoom right now it's me logan paul
casey neistat
mr beast
and a few other friends and he
asked us all who has a crypto punk and i
didn't have one i was kind of like i i
don't have one of those and they're
pretty expensive at the time i thought
they were prohibitively expensive and
it's just a fraction of where they are
today he was just like well if you want
to you know stay on this call whatever
like we're going to go out and buy and
so he kind of forced us all to go out
there and buy punk and this was the punk
that i bought it opened up my eyes to
just like what the marketplace could
provide in terms of collector culture in
terms of the psychology around nfts and
understanding the trading and the
experience of it all this is important
for me i don't think i'll ever get rid
of it there have been a few moments in
the marketplace where i could have
unloaded it and done pretty well
but
again there's a sentimentality around
the crypto punks and especially this one
because without this i don't think i
would have understood the mechanics
around our own project and so this was a
very expensive piece of education for me
how much was it how much is it worth now
oh well was it what was the best offer
you got
it was at the time it was
twenty thousand dollars u.s when punks
were peaking at some point in
the later half of the year there were
probably it was probably
about a half million dollars
which happens with nfts
it's somewhere in between there at this
point um
[Music]
but yeah
crazy